what how's it gonna rise my dear we're
gonna bed we're gonna play twister but
with a twist
are you ready to switch 3 2 1
I don't know okay uh wait twister okay
alright but I'm less okay okay let me
stupid up last times live that's
hardball that's good purple over here I
don't know where your booty is all right
yeah we're purple this guy this is a
terrible idea
left hand green okay your turn
okay which one right yeah right for
yellow
he'll do one more I want that one
right foot yellow red oh my god your ass
waiting okay
left foot blue sure right foot yellow
youichi i didn't ice you you're so fat
right foot blue
right foot yellow
what what am i spinning please not a
foot left foot yup damn it oh my god how
am I supposed to do that okay I got it I
got it
we hope you enjoy this video if you did
leave a like for every light and your
will eat your hand okay brofist
breakfast
Oh invited me you will let go
dieting works